[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein Schokoladeneis mit Brownies.
Eigentlich wollte ich heute was ganz anderes machen.
Dann gucke ich ins Gefrierfach und sehe den Eisbereiter
und ich dachte mir: "Mensch, ich habe dieses Jahr
noch gar nichts mit dem Eisbereiter gemacht."
Und vor allem gibt es ja auch schon viele Eisrezepte von mir
mit und ohne Eismaschine,
aber ich werde einfach immer wieder gefragt:
"Sally, zeig doch auch mal wieder was für den Eisbereiter!"
Heute gibt es ein
– wir haben es einstimmig,
also wirklich alle, alle abgestimmt.
Wir haben gesagt:
Brownie-Eis.
Ich glaube, von Ben & Jerry's gibt es sogar ein Brownie-Eis.
Ich habe es noch nicht
– doch, ich habe es schon probiert.
O mein Gott! Es ist so gut!
Mit so half-baked Brownie-Stückchen drin.
Und deswegen die Basis
bildet jetzt erst mal mein Brownies-Rezept.
Ich habe das auch schon online,
aber ich zeige es euch trotzdem.
So im Schnelldurchlauf machen wir kurz die Brownies
und gehen dann direkt an das
Schokoladeneis.
Für die Brownies brauche ich
230 Gramm Butter,
300 Gramm Zucker,
300 Gramm Zartbitterschokolade,
50 Gramm Kaffee,
– den habe ich bereits rausgelassen –
vier Eier,
eine Prise Salz,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
200 Gramm Mehl,
60 Gramm Kakao,
200 Gramm gehackte Haselnüsse
und 100 Gramm backfeste Schokodrops.
Was ihr jetzt zuerst macht, ist,
ihr nehmt die Butter und den Zucker
und die Zutaten gebt ihr in einen kleinen Topf
oder in eine Schüssel
und erwärmt sie, bis die Butter geschmolzen ist,
aber jetzt nicht kochen lassen.
Also jetzt nicht auf Turbohitze,
sondern wirklich nur mittlere Hitze.
Und ich werde schon mal den Backofen vorheizen
auf 180°C Ober-/Unterhitze.
Und da wollte ich euch auch mal zeigen,
wer die Sallys Welt App hat,
der kann praktisch mit der Sallys Welt App
die Bosch Backöfen Serie 8 einfach steuern.
Die sind ja auch WLAN-gesteuert.
Das heißt, ihr habt auf dem Handy
in meiner kostenlosen App
die Rezepte, könnt sie umrechnen,
könnt die Umrechnungsfunktion benutzen
und wirklich alles digital auch umrechnen lassen.
Da muss keiner mehr was selber machen.
Und dann geht ihr einfach in die App,
klickt das heutige Rezept an
und dann könnt ihr einfach
Einstellungen an den Backofen senden
und der Ofen geht von alleine an.
Wartet. Das mache ich mal kurz.
Das ist nämlich wie Zauberei.
Und im Prinzip,
das ist zwar nur ein Knopfdruck am Backofen,
aber gerade, wenn man sich unsicher ist,
geht man einfach in die App rein,
kann sich einfach nur alles einstellen
und fertig.
Ihr müsst keine Heizart einstellen,
keine Temperatur und auch keine Backzeit.
Also, wie gesagt, könnt ihr normalerweise
auf die Sallys Welt App gehen
und, wenn ihr hier zum Beispiel ein Rezept auswählt,
– das von heute habe ich natürlich noch nicht angelegt,
weil ich noch nicht fertig bin –
aber dann habt ihr ja hier unten drin
"Einstellwerte an den Ofen senden",
klickt hier dran.
"Die Einstellwerte 170°C" und so weiter.
"Jetzt starten".
Ich brauche jetzt 180°C.
Deswegen stelle ich das jetzt ein.
Aber, wie gesagt,
sobald ich dieses Rezept angelegt habe in meiner App,
könnt ihr einfach Fernstart eben aktivieren am Backofen
und dann alles einstellen.
Und das hat jetzt nicht nur den Vorteil,
dass ihr nichts einstellen müsst,
sondern, wenn ihr zum Beispiel wisst,
ihr seid jetzt gerade unterwegs,
ich hole die Ela zum Beispiel vom Kindergarten ab,
dann kann ich ganz einfach vom Handy aus den Ofen starten.
Und, bis wir dann da sind in 20 Minuten,
ist das Essen zum Beispiel fertig.
Also hat schon gute Vorteile.
Oder ich kann den Ofen vorheizen,
wenn ich weiß, ich backe gleich was.
Und, ja, das macht ihr da.
Also hier lasse ich jetzt die Zutaten schmelzen,
aber, wie gesagt, nicht kochen.
Solange kann ich schon mal meinen Backrahmen
aufstellen.
Ich habe jetzt hier nur leider das alte Modell.
Beim neuen Modell habt ihr nämlich die Skalierung dran.
Aber der Murat, der ist ja zurzeit immer im Shop
und der backt dort ganz viel
und hat einfach die Sachen von hier mitgenommen,
als hätte ich nichts im Shop.
Jetzt muss ich es mir kurz ausmessen.
Aber, wie gesagt, die V2-Serie, die hat einfach direkt
die Skalierung mit drauf.
Da kann man es ablesen.
Also 30 cm mal 20 cm.
Wobei, ich gucke mal.
Vielleicht stelle ich ihn später noch größer ein,
damit die Brownies nicht ganz so hoch werden.
Denn für das Eis
nehme ich es größer.
Ja.
Dann jetzt hier einfach den Herd ausschalten,
die Schokolade einrühren
und gerne auch den warmen Kaffee
oder Espresso.
Und jetzt einfach kurz rühren,
bis die Schokolade geschmolzen ist.
Und jetzt fragen bestimmt einige:
"Was kann ich statt Kaffee nehmen?"
Wenn ihr den Kaffee nicht wollt, lasst ihn einfach weg.
Das ist wirklich so eine kleine Menge.
Da macht das dann auch nichts aus,
wenn ihr ihn nicht ersetzt.
Ansonsten nehmt ihr einfach ein bisschen Milch stattdessen.
Die Schokoladenmischung ist jetzt nicht heiß,
sondern wirklich nur noch lauwarm,
da die Schokolade ja kalt war
und sozusagen die Butter dann eben heruntergekühlt hat.
Deswegen kann ich jetzt auch hier direkt
die Eier dazu geben und einrühren.
Da braucht ihr jetzt echt nur eine Schüssel,
also so ein One-Pot-Kuchen.
Dann das Salz dazu geben.
Oh, ich wollte gar keinen Vanilleextrakt.
Ich wollte Tonka Wonka.
Ich glaube,
ich habe kein Tonka Wonka mehr.
Deswegen nehme ich
Tonkabohne.
Denn Tonkabohne in Brownies ist schon gut.
D-d-da-dat!
Ich kreise hier heute in der Küche rum.
Also...
Okay. Also entweder nehmt ihr Vanilleextrakt,
was sehr lecker ist,
oder ihr nehmt Tonka Wonka oder eine Tonkabohne.
Die wird reingerieben.
Bei Tonka Wonka habt ihr einfach den Vorteil,
ihr könnt es nicht überdosieren.
Denn so eine Tonkabohne ist im Prinzip
wie ein Muskatnuss oder auch Zimt
giftig, wenn man einfach zu viel dosiert,
also zu viel verwendet.
Deswegen wirklich nur ganz wenig nehmen
und eben ganz fein reiben.
Da gebe ich jetzt das Mehl und Kakaopulver dazu
und rühre es vorsichtig ein.
Und zwar so vorsichtig, dass keiner sagen kann,
ich hätte eine größere Schüssel nehmen sollen.
Ich darf jetzt nicht kleckern.
Denn der Josh hat gesagt,
er wartet nur auf den Moment.
Ta-daa!
Oh, das riecht so gut!
Der Kaffee, den schmeckt man übrigens nicht raus.
Aber ich finde, der bringt einfach
so eine Geschmacksnote noch mit rein.
Und deswegen nehme ich ihn ganz gerne mit.
Jetzt hier die gerösteten Haselnüsse.
Die sind schon gehackt und nicht gezuckert.
Also das ist kein Krokant, sonst wird es zu süß.
Und die backfesten Schokodrops, die sind zartbitter.
Jetzt noch mal vorsichtig.
Ich glaube, jetzt nehme ich doch einen Rührlöffel.
Ansonsten
weiß ich nicht, was passiert.
[Musik]
Hanuta.
Was war der Werbespruch?
>> JOSH: Ich weiß nicht.
>> SALLY: Das Beste zwischen zwei knusprigen Waffeln.
Nee, das habe ich erfunden.
>> JOSH: Ich glaube es.
Ja, gibt es nicht was, was so in die Richtung geht?
>> SALLY: Aber das war doch auch so Schokocreme
und dann diese gerösteten Haselnüsse.
Und du hast gedacht so:
"Oh, jetzt muss ich in den Fernseher reinbeißen!"
Okay. Schreibt mir mal in die Kommentare so
die Werbesprüche, die euch so auf Knopfdruck
bei einer Werbung einfallen.
So was wie:
– keine Ahnung –
"Globus. Da ist die Welt noch in Ordnung."
"Real. Einmal hin. Alles drin."
So Sachen.
Gut. Jetzt habe ich hier den Teig.
Den fülle ich direkt in die Backform ein.
Oh! Oh!
Yummy! Yummy!
[Musik]
Ich ziehe das Blech jetzt aber noch auf Blechgröße aus.
Denn ich möchte später kleine Brownie-Würfel.
Ich glaube, das sieht dann besser aus.
Und sie backen auch schneller.
Das sind so diese Momente,
die mich dann glücklich machen,
wenn sich so ein Blech voll Brownie-Teig glättet.
[Musik]
Jetzt kommen die Brownies in den Backofen.
Die Backzeit verkürzt sich jetzt natürlich.
Und die Brownies, die brauchen auch keine Stäbchenprobe.
Denn sie sollen innen noch matschig sein,
also wirklich so half-baked.
Und dann sind sie perfekt.
[Musik]
Schaut mal! 15 Minuten waren perfekt.
Die sollen wirklich noch so ein bisschen matschig sein.
Die lasse ich jetzt hier kurz abkühlen
und kann in der Zwischenzeit schon mal
das Schokoladeneis zubereiten.
Denn das ist auch selbst gemacht.
Und das wird superlecker!
Und dafür nehme ich diese Zutaten:
drei Eigelb,
150 Gramm Zucker,
400 Gramm Milch,
30 Gramm Kakao,
100 Gramm Zartbitterschokolade,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
eine Prise Salz,
200 Gramm Sahne
und 50 Gramm Kakaonibs.
Kakaonibs, das ist die ursprüngliche Schokolade,
das heißt einfach gebrochene Kakaobohne.
Im Prinzip wird daraus dann Kakao hergestellt,
Kakaobutter.
Und die sind wirklich megalecker
und sorgen später im Eis für den Crunch.
Denn ich möchte das Eis auch crunchy haben,
habe ich mir gedacht.
So.
Okay.
Als Allererstes verrühre ich jetzt die Eigelbe.
Ich bin hier nach drüben gewandert,
denn ich muss auch gleich an den Herd.
Ich werde jetzt die Eigelbe mit dem Zucker
schön cremig verrühren
und kann aber auch schon mal die Milch erwärmen
hier im Topf
mit Kakao.
So.
Einfach so bei mittlerer Stufe.
Und hier schön weißcremig rühren.
Da gebe ich auch schon das Salz dazu.
[Musik]
Ich muss sagen, normalerweise würde ich jetzt
da einfach die Küchenmaschine nehmen,
weil es schneller geht und ich habe die Hände frei.
Ich wollte das Rezept aber so ein bisschen basic halten.
Denn es hat ja nicht jeder eine Küchenmaschine.
Ihr könnt aber, wenn ihr die Kenwood Cooking Chef habt
oder auch die KitchenAid mit der beheizbaren Rührschüssel,
auch damit arbeiten.
Denn die Eigelbmasse wird jetzt im Prinzip
weißcremig geschlagen.
Das mache ich jetzt mit dem Handrührgerät.
Und die Masse wird später auch noch erhitzt.
Von daher ist es eigentlich auch ganz praktisch,
die Maschine zu benutzen.
[Musik]
Was ich hier auch schon dazu geben kann,
ist das Vanilleextrakt.
Passt auch perfekt zu Schokoladeneis.
Und, sobald hier drüben
die Masse lauwarm ist,
also so
etwas wärmer als lauwarm,
schon so 60, 70°C,
kann ich schon die Schokolade einrühren.
Also für meine Hände lauwarm,
für andere Hände heiß.
Ich würde den Finger jetzt nicht mehr reinstecken.
Jetzt kann ich hier die Schokolade einrühren.
Komm, Josh, das hast du gedacht, oder?
>> JOSH: Ja!
>> SALLY: Sallys Lauwarm.
>> JOSH: "So lauwarm
– ach ja, 60, 70°C."
>> SALLY: Hier die Schokolade schmelzen lassen.
Und ich arbeite wirklich auf sehr niedriger Stufe.
Es soll ja nicht kochen.
Und hier weiter cremig rühren.
[Musik]
Da sind wir jetzt wieder bei diesem Thema:
Kannst du mit der einen Hand nach rechts drehen
und die andere macht es...
Das kann ich nicht.
Weißt du?
Jetzt rechtsrum, da kann ich auch rechtsrum.
Und linksrum auch.
Und ich kann auch so
und ich kann auch so.
Aber ich kann jetzt nicht hier rund
und hier so ein Streifen.
>> JOSH: Das ist schwierig, ja.
>> SALLY: Rund, rund, rund, rund.
Streifen.
Nein.
>> JOSH: Du musst einmal probieren,
einen Kreis und ein Dreieck zu machen.
>> SALLY: Kreis, Kreis, Kreis, Kreis.
Kreis.
Dreieck.
Das geht nicht!
Weil dein Hirn konzentriert sich
auf diesen Kreis.
Ich kann es nicht.
Aber es gibt Menschen, die können so was.
Okay. Dann haben wir das.
Die Schokolade hat sich aufgelöst.
Hört man mich eigentlich?
Hört man mich?
Gut.
So.
Jetzt kann ich die hier ganz vorsichtig reingießen.
Denn sie ist ja nicht heiß,
sondern nur warm, wie wir wissen.
Wenn sie zu heiß ist, dann entsteht nämlich Rührei.
[Musik]
Ich wollte gerade sagen so:
"Hey, ist egal, wie es jetzt hier aussieht.
Ich mache einfach weiter."
Und dann dachte ich so: "Nee, das ist nicht meine Art.
Ganz und gar nicht."
Ich muss hier kurz den Herd sauber machen
und, oh, mein Handy
und, oh, bis da vorne.
Ups!
Ups, ups, ups!
So.
Jetzt habe ich hier
die Schokomasse.
Die kommt jetzt wieder zurück in den Topf.
Macht voll Sinn, in einem Topf zu rühren,
wenn noch nichts drin ist.
Und jetzt wird die Masse so ein bisschen eingedickt.
Also auch nicht kochen lassen,
sondern eher so auf 80°C ungefähr erhitzen.
Das heißt für alle, die jetzt kein Thermometer besitzen
oder keinen PerfectCook
oder keine Küchenmaschine mit Hitzefunktion,
einfach so etwa zwei, drei Minuten lang erwärmen
bei mittelhoher Hitze.
Und dann reicht uns das auch schon.
Aber, wenn ihr Gerätschaften und technische Hilfsmittel habt,
dann benutzt sie ruhig.
Dann müsst ihr nicht dastehen und ständig rühren,
sondern könnt einfach die Maschine rühren lassen.
Ich mache das jetzt hier einfach mit dem PerfectCook-Sensor.
Und ich kann den auf Stufe 1 auf 70°C einstellen,
Stufe 2 auf 90°C.
Ich habe jetzt hier einfach Stufe 1,
warte auf die 70°C
und dann erwärme ich es einfach noch ein bisschen
und habe so ungefähr 80°C.
Aber, wie gesagt, zwei, drei Minuten erwärmen,
dass es leicht eindickt.
Das reicht dann auch.
[Musik]
Bei mir hat die Masse jetzt die perfekte Temperatur.
Und vielleicht noch zum Hintergrundwissen:
Man muss es erhitzen,
damit man einfach ein schönes cremiges Eis bekommt.
Hat auch den Vorteil, dass zum Beispiel Salmonellen,
die auf der Eierschale lagen, eben auch getötet werden
durch das Erhitzen der Eimasse.
Aber eigentlich macht man es wirklich nur,
damit das Eis cremig wird.
Denn, wird es nicht erhitzt, wird es einfach nicht cremig.
Wird es zu stark erhitzt, also kocht die Masse bereits,
dann gerinnt ja das Ei
und dann verliert es einfach diese cremige Eigenschaft.
Und jetzt könnt ihr den Holzlöffeltest machen.
Also, wie gesagt, bei mir war jetzt alles super.
Und jetzt nehmt ihr einen Löffel
– müsste vielleicht auch
mit einem anderen Löffel funktionieren –
und ihr nehmt so ein bisschen von der Masse.
Also ich sehe es eigentlich hier schon,
es ist noch zu flüssig.
Aber ich zeige euch mal:
Wenn ihr draufpustet, entstehen praktisch keine Wellen,
sondern die Masse neigt sich einfach zur Seite.
Jetzt lasse ich es noch ein bisschen erwärmen.
Aber, wie gesagt, kochen darf es nicht.
Denn sonst ist die Bindeeigenschaft auch weg.
Schön geduldig.
Schaut mal. Jetzt ist es dickflüssiger.
Jetzt fülle ich die Masse hier um.
Denn die muss jetzt erst mal abkühlen.
So kann ich sie noch nicht in die Eismaschine stecken.
Wäre einfach noch zu heiß.
Und außerdem fehlt hier noch meine Sahne.
Die gebe ich jetzt einfach auch noch dazu.
Die kühlt das Ganze jetzt auch schon mal ab.
Und ich lasse es jetzt erst mal bei Raumtemperatur abkühlen,
gebe es dann noch in den Kühlschrank,
damit die Eismasse schön kalt ist.
Und die Kakaonibs, die kommen erst später dazu,
wenn das Eis in der Eismaschine ist.
Ich werde mein Eis jetzt im Eisbereiter zubereiten.
Das hat den Vorteil,
dass ich innerhalb von 20 bis 30 Minuten schon ein Eis habe,
und ich muss nicht ständig rühren.
Wenn ihr keinen Eisbereiter habt, gebt ihr dieses Eis,
also die Eismasse, in eine flache Auflaufschale zum Beispiel,
gebt es ins Gefrierfach und rührt dann ungefähr jede Stunde
oder jede halbe Stunde mal durch,
damit es eben auch cremig wird.
Beim Eisbereiter ist jetzt nur wichtig,
hier das reinsetzen
– das passt –
und dann das Eis erst reingeben, wenn es schon rührt.
Ansonsten friert nämlich das Rührelement fest.
[Musik]
Den Eisbereiter gibt es zum Beispiel auch für die Kenwood
oder auch
allein stehende Eisbereiter.
Aber, wie gesagt, geht das Ganze auch ohne.
Aber so wird es halt schon
richtig schön cremig.
Und ich lasse jetzt das Eis schon mal gefrieren
und werde in der Zwischenzeit
die Brownies schon mal in kleine Würfelchen schneiden.
Und die Kakaonibs,
die gebe ich dann aber erst zum Schluss dazu,
wenn es wirklich schon gefroren ist.
Hier jetzt also einfach den Backrahmen lösen.
Mit einem Backformmesser geht das ganz gut.
Und dann die Backfolie wegziehen
und die Brownies in kleine Würfel schneiden.
Ich glaube, mit dem Bisiklet klappt das auch.
Ich hoffe es.
[Musik]
Ah, am Ende kracht es durch.
Ich will jetzt aber nur das halbe Blech schneiden
oder sogar nur ein Drittel.
Denn das übrige hier
benutze ich zum Anrichten.
Es wird ein Brownie, wo Brownie-Eis drauf ist.
Also wirklich nur so ein Drittel benutzen
und den restlichen Brownie dann
zum Servieren.
Josh, du musst mal probieren,
weil nicht dass die Brownies jetzt nicht schmecken und dann
haben wir den Salat.
>> JOSH: Wir können weitermachen, glaube ich.
Ziemlich, ja.
Ah nee, warte.
>> SALLY: Oder musst du noch mal?
>> JOSH: Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Ja, doch. Auf jeden Fall!
>> SALLY: Mh.
Nee, ich glaube, wir müssen die Brownies aufessen.
Okay. Jetzt warten wir auf das Eis.
Hm.
Die Brownie-Stückchen,
die friere ich aber schon mal ein.
Dann sind die nämlich schon mal kalt.
Das Eis sieht gut aus.
[Musik]
Das Eis sieht gigantisch aus!
Ich habe jetzt hier die Brownie-Stücke.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach so einen Emailleteller,
einen tiefen, großen.
Den hätte ich vorher einfrieren sollen.
Guckt euch dieses Eis an!
Ist das lecker?
Ja!
Einen Fehler dürft ihr niemals machen:
Niemals mit scharfen Gegenständen in den Eisbereiter rein
und niemals das Eis im Eisbereiter einfrieren.
Man muss es einfach rausnehmen.
Dient einfach dem Schutz des Eisbereiters,
dass die Oberfläche nicht zerstört wird.
Wirklich schön mit einem Teigschaber arbeiten.
Und das ging jetzt schon relativ schnell, gell, Josh?
So 20 Minuten.
>> JOSH: In den Rührtopf rein und dann schon.
>> SALLY: Rein, anschalten, fertig.
Das lasse ich mal da zum
Probieren.
Und jetzt hier umfüllen.
Ihr seht auch, ganz toll cremig.
Und entweder nehmt ihr es jetzt so schon als Softeis
– es kommt halt auch auf die Außentemperatur an.
Unsere Küche ist immer ziemlich warm,
weil ich einfach ganz viele Öfen gleichzeitig anhabe.
Daher kann es auch sein,
wenn ihr im Hochsommer Eis macht,
dass ihr es einfach noch ein bisschen länger einfrieren müsst.
Ist aber nicht schlimm.
Es wäre so jetzt schon verzehrbereit.
Aber ich habe es jetzt ganz gerne,
dass ich wirklich mit einem Eisportionierer
auch Kugeln abstechen kann.
Hier kommen jetzt die Kakaonibs rein
für den Crunch.
Und die Würfel!
Half-baked Brownie-Würfel.
Ich glaube, ich vermische es jetzt noch gar nicht.
Das mache ich später.
Ein paar hebe ich mir auf für das Topping.
Und jetzt kommt es in den Gefrierschrank
für etwa eine Stunde noch mal.
Und dann probieren wir.
Also, was ihr über das Eis wissen müsst, ist,
da sind ja keine Konservierungsstoffe drin,
keine Emulgatoren.
Es ist wirklich ein Eis, was man auch,
wenn es aus dem Gefrierfach kommt,
ziemlich zeitnah verzehren sollte.
Und ich werde jetzt diese Brownies noch nehmen.
O mein Gott! Sie sind so schön!
Und das ist der Untergrund für das Eis.
Und alleine beim Brownies-Schneiden
läuft mir das Wasser im Mund zusammen.
Denn die sind halt wirklich so...
Guck dir das an!
So richtig so half-baked Brownie.
Njam, njam!
Ich glaube, ich muss tatsächlich
– also für das Bild muss ich
gleich so zwei übereinander machen.
Yes!
Und hier
zack!
Und zack!
Yes!
Yummy, yummy, yummy!
Josh, weißt du was?
Ich lasse dich probieren.
Darf ich so mit dem Finger?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ups!
Darf ich so?
Hier.
O Mann!
Das ist so...
Okay. Es tropft gleich entweder auf dein Shirt oder
– zack!
Ui!
Auf seinen Fuß!
Ach, mit diesen Brownie-Stückchen!
O mein Gott!
Mmh!
Ich muss schon sagen:
O mein Gott!
>> JOSH: Also es ist wirklich eine absolute Schokobombe.
Das ist der Wahnsinn!
>> SALLY: Hm.
Also...
O Gott! Ich wollte euch auch probieren lassen.
Hm?
>> SARAH: Ist der Wahnsinn, die Schokobombe, oder?
>> SALLY: Der Wahnsinn, ja.
Hier, Girls.
Nicht auf meinen Laptop!
Und?
Ist schon gut, gell?
Also ich muss sagen,
persönlich finde ich es natürlich auf dem Brownie,
dann ist es halt schon – gell? –
dann ist es halt schon mächtig.
Aber
optisch sieht es halt mega aus auf dem Brownie.
Deswegen probiert es unbedingt mal aus!
Bereitet das Brownie-Eis zu!
Ich werde es jetzt gleich wieder einfrieren
und dann gönnen wir uns gleich alle noch mal eine Kugel.
Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Schreibt mir gerne,
wenn ich weitere Eiskreationen machen soll,
und schreibt mir auch gerne eure Wünsche.
Also bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüssi!
Ich glaube,
die kleine Samira würde sagen After-Eight-Eis.
Waldmeistereis war mein Eis aus meiner Kindheit.
Da hatte ich immer so eine Waldmeisterkugel
auf so einer Waffel
und dann diese fest werdende Schokolade,
also in Kuvertüre.
Und dann wird die so fest und dann beißt du so rein
und hast so diese dunkle Schokolade
und dann diesen giftgrünen Waldmeisterkern.
Und ich denke mir so: "Woah!"
Das war mein Eis.
[Musik]